all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here Darius you're a Wall Street Insider
you've been talking to all the big boys
giving out all of the money from the
institutions we are on the doorstep of a
Bitcoin spot ETF approval there's tons
of people on the internet that are
excited what's going on on Wall Street
are they excited do they even know this
is happening yet yeah that's a great
question man so everyone knows it's
happening we're all well aware of the
potential pending Black Rock and Fidel
ETF approvals there's obviously other uh
ETF players in the in the game uh as
well uh in terms of the folks we talked
to so we have a very unique uh client
base here at 42 macro particularly as it
relates to uh you know kind of the upper
echelon of global Wall Street they're
all very aware of Bitcoin and of the
cryptocurrency asset class in general
through our research it's always been a
core feature of our research here at 42
macro we treat Bitcoin cryptocurrencies
just like any other asset class whether
they be stocks bonds Commodities Etc
because we believe that our quantitative
management tools and our qualitative
research process can support us
generating you know thoughtful and and
ultimately accurate recommendations on
that asset class so when I talk to 42
macro clients whether they be fixed
income PMS you know looking to allocate
to bitcoin and their pa or they be you
know U you know sort of um ra type
investors who are looking to add Bitcoin
type exposure into their client uh uh uh
portfolios they're all you know it's two
thumbs up now obviously we're you know
it's the two thumbs up because we've
seeing a lot of positive price momentum
uh in in in the chart and so clearly
folks are going to be more interested in
chasing uh what's been working as
opposed to chasing something that hasn't
been working but generally speaking the
the the the reception has been quite
warm uh but it's only because we've been
again focused on crypto and Bitcoin
specifically uh really since the
Inception of our firm now when we look
at the ETF specifically there's a lot of
people who might be excited about
Bitcoin and some of them went and create
a coinbase account or you know went and
bought Bitcoin in some other way are
there people who are sitting there
saying I want Bitcoin but I can't do it
until there's an ETF like is the
structure actually an important part to
unlock some Capital allocation here 100%
yeah they very much is when I talk to
investors the number one thing that
everyone hate not the number one thing
it's there's a lot of things that people
hate particularly about taxes but the
number one thing people hate about taxes
is having to file K1 it's having to deal
with the K1 uh reporting and all that
kind of stuff because it just throws a
real big monkey wrench uh into uh into
the tax uh uh you know tax reporting so
the reality is an ETF is a very tax
efficient vehicle for you know all asset
classes obviously uh the inclusion of
Bitcoin would be very favorable there
and so you could see what I'm I'm
expecting to see is that over time we're
going to going to see a lot of that you
know multi-trillion dollar asset class
that is you know investment advisory
type you know allocations you know folks
that have their money park with u you
know kind of financial advisers we're
going to see a lot of that flow start to
turn at the margins to away from things
like gold and other Alternatives like
Commodities real estate Etc and into the
Bitcoin asset class now the Bitcoin
asset class is is most is likely to
experience uh aggressive inflows when
we're in a Goldilocks regime uh from
from a top down Market regime standpoint
which is what we're currently
experiencing now um and so as long as
that go loocks regime persists we're
going to have a very warm welcome to the
inclusion of Bitcoin in terms of the ET
in terms of the approval of the Bitcoin
ETF if we were approving the Bitcoin ETF
in a deflation or inflation regime um
that you know which are riskof regimes
that would be a lot less supportive now
what it's also interesting to me is uh
everyone is talking about what I'm going
to call primary allocation to the ETF
that is an institution or an investor
they see the ETF gets approved go and
they put Capital into it there is now
cracking signs of what I'm going to call
secondary allocation and what I mean by
that is uh there are other ETFs or other
publicly traded funds that are saying
wait a second if an ETF gets approved I
can now take some of my assets and put
them in the ETF of Bitcoin so I get
Bitcoin exposure for my investors and so
there is uh one example where somebody
has already gone they've man or already
updated the Mandate or the charter of
their publicly traded fund where they
can put up to 15% of their AUM in the
Bitcoin ETF and so to me it's like wait
a second the primary allocations is
obviously going to be large over time
and and people are excited about but
could the ETF actually suck some of the
assets from other ETFs into it where
people who have actively managed funds
or even may have passive Le managed
funds just say look I want Bitcoin
exposure as well and so now if I put a
little bit of my AUM in there I could
draw in more inflows to my Bitcoin ETF
100% And that that's that's going to be
two-sided right you know there's
obviously you know for all that
potential reward there's obviously risk
as well but generally speaking this is
an asset class that has shown it's quite
durable and has perform really well over
long periods of time and we would expect
that to continue uh just given some of
the longer term research we've done on
the four turning Etc we have to unpack
that now so yes I agree uh one of the
things we've you and I talked about
about a month ago or so on this program
about our kiss portfol construction
process which features up to a maximum
allocation of 10 % Bitcoin so that's 60%
spy 30% a which is the fixed in core
fixed income ETF and then 10% Bitcoin
and we use our quantitative resp
Management Systems to sort of you know
dial up or dial down our exposure to any
one of those asset classes at any given
juncture right now it's currently fully
invested um you know we don't predict
the predictors in terms of the things
that the systems that use that we use to
dial up or dial down that exposure but
obviously if we start to dial down that
exposure our clients are going to get
those signals in real time what is the
macro weather model that you all have
saying their current regime is but also
how do you look at maybe the next you
know 90 days or so uh given this model
yeah so that's a great question uh so uh
we put together this uh this chart here
for you for your viewers pump um they s
of showing our macro weather models and
so what let me just take a step back you
know so this macro weather model uh we
use this system this this this
quantitative risk management system to
determine how long the current top- down
Market regime is likely to persist right
now we are currently in Goldilocks
obviously Goldilocks is at risk on
regime is quite bullish for both stocks
bonds uh it's pretty much only bearish
for things like the dollar um and dollar
type assets like volatility Etc and so
uh in terms of our kiss portfolio
construction process we use the signals
the composite signals which are right
there in the middle of the page to dial
up or dial down our Target exposure per
the asset class you know we start the
maximum Target exposure of 60% in the
stock Equity asset class the maximum
exposure of 30% in fixed income asset
class and the maximum exposure of 10% uh
in the uh in the um in in in the Bitcoin
asset class and so if the weather model
signals are bullish then you get maximum
exposure if they're neutral then we dial
that down and if we if they're bearish
we dial that uh uh down incrementally so
um you know this is this system helps us
stay on the right side of Market of of
fundamental macroeconomic Risk by you
know sort of you know feeding in by
tracking and ultimately regime
segmenting the principal components of
macro uh in a way that creates very
valid very powerful signal on a rolling
three-month FL basis for these for these
primary asset classes what about Bitcoin
specifically within this model like you
can break out by asset um and it looks
like uh the sharp ratio uh gets quite
attractive uh on bitcoin it help us
understand this yeah absolutely so what
this chart here the second chart shows
you uh you know sort of just the
evolution the top panel in that chart
shows the evolution of the macro weather
model signals for the Bitcoin asset
class and as you can see you know it
tends to the Bitcoin tends to rise
materially uh when you are in a bullish
uh composite signal regime for that for
that particular asset class in so much
that all the crypto Winters we've
experienced particularly over the last
kind of um the 10 years or so have
occurred when we were in bearish regimes
for Bitcoin uh what that chart on the
bottom the bottom panel shows uh is um
is the evolution of you know the back
test if you use the uh composite signal
for Bitcoin to trade Bitcoin I.E by
being fully invested in Bitcoin when
it's bullish by cutting that position in
half when it's neutral in terms of the
composite signal and then actually
rotating out of the the asset class
fully uh when when it's a bearish
composite signal it just shows you uh
the relation the the the performance of
that uh system of that back test that
out of sample back test relative to the
evolution of Bitcoin and so what is
showing you is that by using our macro
weather model composite signals as an
overlay as a top- down risk management
overlay for this particular asset class
or any asset class uh what it's
ultimately designing to do is help you
step aside when there's volatility ahead
in financial markets and it actually
does uh what I think a lot of investors
do very poorly which is actually get you
back in when it's time to get back in
and actually participate uh in some
upsid so uh quite proud of this system
obviously it's been driven by going back
to that previous page all the principal
components of macro starting with the
real economy cycles and then over to the
financial economy Cycles there on the
left of that page when you look at
Global liquidity that seems to be the
number one driver of a lot of Bitcoins
uh price movement specifically
um how do you anticipate some of this
right so interest rate Cuts obviously
people are saying hey we're going to get
it by kind of end of Q2 um interest rate
cuts are not necessarily
completely 100% correlated to what is
going to happen when it comes to Global
liquidity and also what the US does is
not dominate globally at all times and
so how do you think Global liquidity
changes when it comes through beginning
of 2024 into the end this is something
where it's just on line Trend and we get
more and more liquidity into the market
we should expect interest trades
globally to go down or do we have to
kind of pay attention on a quarter by
quarter a month-by-month basis because
we actually expect uh maybe some Nuance
you know here both globally and also
when it comes to liquidity yeah so I
think uh we're among the world's Elite
expecting and ultimately projecting that
Nuance so there is always nuance and
what with the we models designed to do
is to summarize the Nuance in a way that
allows you to create really powerful and
accurate signals for for the particular
asset class so uh we're talking about
liquidity so let's focus our eyes on the
liquidity uh component up there in the
top right so it's the first set of um
set of indicators under the financial
economy Cycles um you know in terms of
uh in terms of this macro weather model
signal and as you can see 42 macronet
liquidity that's the FED balance sheet
minus the TGA balance minus the RP
balance that model was trending higher
uh it's trending higher so it's
obviously creating positive uh impulse
for for for the risky asset classes as
well as our Global liquidity proxy which
we found to be a much more statistically
significant model in terms of uh
projecting uh asset market performance
uh that's the that the global central
bank balance sheet plus global broad
money supply plus global FX reserves
minus gold that number is also trending
higher as well answering your question
specifically so we we've performed a lot
of statistical analysis in terms of the
drivers of liquidity so things that you
know typically Drive liquidity are
fluctuations in the currency Market
particularly when they're being driven
by regime change in volatility in the
currency Market volatility in the fixed
income Market uh other factors that are
leading indicators for liquidity are
changes in in the employment picture in
key economies like the US United States
and and the major economies in the world
uh changes in inflation changes in
growth so we we've done a tremendous
amount of statistical analysis that we
perform and and distribute to our our
clients here at 42 macro to understand
those dynamics of what actually leads
the liquidity cycle because ultimately
you need to predict what's happening in
liquidity if you want to project what's
likely to occur in asset markets and
right now we're seeing a lot of positive
signals uh that are supportive of the
private sector's uh liquidity creation
function and so I think one thing um you
know as investors you know not not we at
42 macro but but a lot of investors I
see still see out there um kind of um
spend too much time focusing just solely
on Central Bank liquidity and some
investors have taken that a step further
and focused on liquidity from from key
financial or say key fiscal players like
you know the bank of Japan or sorry
Japanese Ministry of Finance or the US
Treasury Department but the reality is
the public sector only creates you know
a portion of liquidity you know the
other portion of liquidity and quite
dominant sometimes is the private sector
you know the global bank and non-bank
financial sector uh these these
institutions create a lot of liquidity
as well and they tend to have they tend
to create liquidity on a counter
cyclical basis uh to things like
volatility and asset markets you know
big spikes in energy uh big spikes in
the dollar Etc so right now the things
that are drive that lead the counter
cyclical um you know impulse liquidity
impulse are still signaling quite
favorably for liquidity to Trend higher
over the medium term uh but those things
could change in any given time and this
is why one of the core features of our
process just generally here at 42 macro
is a basy and insistence upon refreshing
the same models and the same data every
single day you see that 13 2024 at the
top in the middle of that chart tomorrow
we're going to refresh the model it's
going to say4 2024 and the day after
it's going to say 15 2024 at some point
those up arrows in the liquidity section
will inflect sideways or down and when
they inflect sideways or down it's going
to say hey stock market you used to be
bullish but you're probably going to be
neutral now over the next three months
or if they inflect down and say you used
to be bullish but you're probably going
to be bearish over the next three months
and so we you know refreshing that these
all these systems in in real time this
is just one of our our Key Systems
refreshing them in real time on a daily
basis allows us to spot those critical
inflections in real time so that we can
do something about it in our
portfolios when you see um investors
using these models what do you think is
the biggest thing that they get wrong
you mentioned Global liquidity and too
much of a focus there what what are some
of the other major mistakes uh well to
me the major mistake is is that
investors tend to it just from process
standpoint investors tend to myopically
focus on what they're focused on right
now that doesn't sound particularly
smart but what I mean by is is when
investors are bearish they tend to find
they tend to go do research on things
that lead them further down the bearish
rabbit hole in so much that when when
investors are bullish they tend to do
more research on things that lead them
down the bullish rabbit hole and what
we're trying to do at 42 macro is just
dispassionately only do research on
everything every single day and
summarize that you know very succinctly
for our clients so that when we are
going from state in the markets where
they're bullish generally bullish and to
bearish we're actually you know able to
spot that in real time you know our
process you know we you know we kind of
we fasing ourselves as Trend followers
understanding that momentum in both
asset markets and in the economy are two
of the most powerful forces in finance
and if you are fighting that powerful
force you're generally going to have
poor results over a long period of time
and so we Orient our you know risk
management and our research process
around trying to identify you know
Trends and momentum from a research
standpoint from a fundamental standpoint
across all these principal components of
macro but we're also trying to do that
in terms of identifying Trends and
momentum from a from a from a market
standpoint and we're marrying those two
separate processes into actionable uh
portfolio construction guidance for our
clients and so when you when you know
answering your question what do people
tend to get wrong I the number one thing
I see people get wrong is they don't
look at the same stuff day after day
after day after day after day you know
in order to spot those critical
inflections and momentum in the asset
markets and in the economy what they're
doing is well I think they're for and to
me I think therefore for is is
consistently proven particularly over
the last few years to be be quite quite
quite a harmful experience for a lot of
investors what do you think that the
best investors do that the worst
investors don't and what I mean by that
is like everyone makes mistakes everyone
has these commonalities right of where
they could get tripped up but in my
experience the best at anything take for
example uh you know maybe baseball the
best hitter does one thing exceptionally
well that everyone else struggles with
or or doesn't put much Obsession and
kind of focus on is there things like
that when it comes to investors that
you've interfaced with that you find
there's one thing that they do better
than everyone else and really has them
stand out and drives their performance
yeah 100% man to me it's about being uh
more systematic than less systematic you
know a lot of what we do at 42 macro is
a you know it's really just the the
summary of all my learning and
experience on global Wall Street for the
past 15 years you know I I've lost count
but I'm somewhere close to 45 so 4,500
meetings with institutional investors
the large you know everyone you know the
who's who's of global Wall Street you
know I spent most of my career flying
around the world meeting with these
investors having deep discussions about
portfolio construction asset allocation
building econometric models and things
of that nature that's my that's my
background and so you know when I you
know all the stuff that I've learned
from those those those key players on
the buy side throughout my career you
know the number one thing that I see
that they do that the average investor
doesn't and certainly the the average
you know retail and ra type investor
does not do uh is being systematic about
their research and systematic about
their risk management and notice that I
said research and risk management not
just research or risk management those
are two separate processes and they keep
them very separate you know the research
process is allow you know if you're
systematic about your research you're
looking at the same data sets every week
every month to identify you know
critical inflections in those data sets
that that really pertain to uh to to the
key economic outcomes that we all care
about in financial markets being
systematic about your risk management
you know means you are you know you're
dispassionately executing your risk
management process and you're not you
know you're not being beholden to what's
currently happening in markets or you're
beholding to your gut feeling about
what's going to happen uh in in asset
markets and to me that that that's the
number one thing that I see the best
performing funds the best managers the
richest people who are buying all those
expensive luxury apartments everywhere
that's what they do that we try to do
and Infuse in t our process at 42 macro
we have a you know bird's eye view a
real Insider knowledge of of those
processes and that's what you see on the
screen here in terms of our weather
model and the other things that we do at
42 macro makes complete sense to me
where can we send people to find you
online or find out more about 42 macro I
appreciate that pom so obviously come
check us out 42 macro.com is our is our
website we put out a lot of uh you know
sort of educational and and Market uh
guidance uh uh for free on Twitter as
well LinkedIn so I'm at Darius Dale 42
on Twitter you can follow me on LinkedIn
as well at Darius Dale appreciate
everyone for checking us out we'll do it
again in the future my friend cheers man
thank you very much catch guys everyone
have a happy new year best of luck out
there in 2024 and we'll be uh we'll be
here right alongside we will be here
with you all along the way helping you
make a save money in financial markets